the bachelor in paradise cast is getting  seriously dramatic and we love it we  already knew we were getting this  season's bachelorettes villain shad  what's up you're welcome Here I am but  now a source tells ET Josh Marie and  Nick Viall will both be in Paradise  which started filming earlier this month  31 year old Josh and 35 year old Nick  had plenty of bad blood after their  season as contestants on The  Bachelorette Andi Dorfman ultimately  chose Josh over Nick in the 2014 finale  and things got especially weird when  Nick made this awkward reveal on after  the final rose if you weren't in love  with me  it's not sure why  like why you made lovely I don't well  first of all I think that's coming below  the belt Josh and Andi ended their  relationship in January and she has  since written a book about her love  stories tell us who you're most excited  to see on paradise tweet us at UT now